voici tout ce qui va changer en France à
partir du 1er avril 2023 contrairement à
ce qui a pu être annoncé la fin des
tickets de caisse papier n'aura pas lieu
à partir du 1er avril cette mesure
écologique est reportée car beaucoup de
Français soient vérifier l'exactitude du
montant des courses qu'ils font indique
le gouvernement à parisien la trêve
hivernale se termine et les locataires
peuvent à nouveau être expulsés en cas
de loyer impayés en cas de facture
d'électricité impayée la puissance du
courant sera réduite pendant 60 jours
avant d'être coupé si vous bénéficiez du
chèque énergie ou du net du fond de
solidarité pour le logement plusieurs
prestations sociales comme le RSA les
allocations familiales ou la prime
d'activité augmente de 1,6%. les
personnes souhaitant passer le brevet
d'aptitude aux fonctions d'animateur le
BAFA et qui ont effectué une mission de
service civique depuis janvier 2022
pourront bénéficier de 100 euros pour
préparer le BAFA les passoires
thermiques c'est-à-dire les logements
dans l'étiquette DPE est classée F ou G
auront l'obligation de réaliser un audit
énergétique préalablement à leur mise en
vente les chèques énergie d'un montant
allant de 48 à 277 euros en fonction de
vos revenus et de votre consommation
vont être progressivement envoyés au
cours du mois